en Ukraine cet engin pourra sauver des
milliers de vie il est capable de
déminer près de 2400 mètres carrés de
sol par heure le tout à distance un
engin unique que l'Ukraine vient
d'acquérir grâce à l'aide internationale
les principalement destiné à préserver
la vie et la santé de nos spécialistes
du déminage
avant de venir en Ukraine elle a opéré
dans plus de six pays dans le monde
notamment l'Afghanistan l'alibi l'Irak
et d'autres pays en proie à des conflits
mondiaux
selon Kiev la moitié du pays se réminait
depuis le début de l'invasion plus de 80
000 engins explosifs ont été désamorcés
alors pour assainir les sols de nombreux
ukrainiens ont décidé de s'engager c'est
le cas de lexandra cette vétérinaire a
rejoint l'unité de déminage de la police
de mikolaïve les troupes russes se sont
retirés de la ville et ont laissé une
quantité considérable d'explosifs
l'équipe et débordée
ukrainien il faudra au moins une
décennie pour éliminer toutes les mines
et tous les explosifs en Ukraine